ここは、はじめの撮影部屋
扉を開けるとそこには…
予想以上に服が散らかっていました
少し前に、服が多すぎて
50着売ったっていう動画を出したんですよ
で
僕の中ではもう服は、ほぼ、無くなったと思ってたんですけども
洗濯機に入ってたんだよね
洗濯機に入ってた分を洗濯して乾かして家に入れたら、
服が増えてしまった。
さっき見てもらったと思うんですけども
このね!
俺の使ってる服の棚には、服は入らない
これ抜けたっけ?
うぉっ、うわぁ!
パジャマ、アンド下着
パジャマと下着がもぅ、こんだけ、もう溢れかえってます
うぇあぁ!!
こっちが上の服～
こんだけパンパンなんですけどまだ床に散乱するレベルで入っていると
うぇあ!
下のズボンは～
ま、そうでもありません
3つだけの棚だとー
服、を、入れるのに限界を感じました
入らないんすよ!!
晴れた日が続くと洗濯しますと
干しますー
家に、入れますー
取り込みますー
たたみますー
入れる場所がない。
思ったよりまだー
服があったみたいです
服を入れる場所がなくて非常に困ってたんでー
今回新しく!
ちょっとこうゆう、服を入れる棚みたいなやつを買ってみました
もう下に届いているみたいなんでぇ
早速、見に行ってみましょう!!
へたこいた～!!!
もうちょっと、小さいと思ってました
もうちょっと小さいと思ってたんですけども、
7本入りのやつを、4つ、買いました
そしたら～
…思ったよりデカかった!
あのさほら、釜爺がいるじゃん?
釜爺のあの感じ(笑)
www
釜爺のあの感じを出せればいいなと思ってるんで～
7個入りが～、4つで
20…8個分!　棚があるのでー
出来るっしょ!
28棚あるんだよ?
ま、棚はー、あって困るものではありません
物を収納できるようになるんで
ここで開封してからー、
上に持っていく?
ハッパかけて出しますか～
えぇえ!?　やぁっ…
ほんとに?
いっちゃうよ?　このまま
ああっっ!!
っ゛あ゛っ!
思ったより!　大きいチェストが28個来てしまったんですけども
頑張ってチェストを28個、部屋に設置していこうと思います
じゃ早速です設置していきまっしょう!
痛ッッ!!
あぁ!!　あ゛あ゛、あ゛あッッ!!!
あー、こんな感じかー
あああぁぁぁあ!!!
こんな感じのやつです
ガタンやだ
ガタンやだ!
ガタンやだ…
あぁっ!…
あ～～～。
うぅっ!
あああああああ!!!!!
ああああああ!!　っはははは…
わあぁっ!
%#☆?◎…ああっ!?
なんで落ちてきたし(笑)
%#☆?◎
%#☆?◎落ちてきた
ねぇ、ちょっと待って(笑)
なんでなんで?
落ちるんだもん
どうしよどうしよ
何か使うしかない
段ボール、乗れそうじゃない?
あぁっ…
えあああぁぁぁああ!!!!!
こんなところで役に立つとはな
オッケっ!
あ、オッケっ!　来ました～
無事!
チェストを4つ
段ボールから出したので～
早速!
これうぉ!
家の!
中の方に!
入れていこうと
思いまぁす
では行こう!
1個目いきまぁす!
デカいね
うわぁ
いててててて!
いててででで!!!
なんかぽくなぃ!?
ぅお～ん、いいねー
部屋が超小さくなっちゃうょ
こうゆう感じっすね
こうゆう感じです!
ひとまずこうゆう感じで置いていきたい
素晴らしい
あと、3ついきましょう
もう、何が何でもー
僕の棚なんで!!
全部自分の力で、絶対持っていきます
あ。
あ、横いい!　横!
横持ちやすい!!
いたいいたい゛い゛たい!!!
厳しくない?　でも
これ、このままこっちに寄せるからー、所沢が邪魔になっちゃう
っちょ、今思ったんですけどー
この!
タンス2つにー
こいつら。
所沢はもう、メインキャスター(キャスト)だからここに置いといてー
井上を!　一時的にちょっと、移動させましょう
いや、ほんと申し訳ない
スペースの関係で、ちょっと仕方ないんすよー
ダークネス井上はー、ひとまず僕と一緒に寝ることにします
…よし
もうー、ここまできたら俺が全部やるしかねぇ
全部やります!
…ぅうっ
わあああぁぁぁああ!!!
指!!
骨折れた。
ぅう…っ
ぅいぃたっっ!!!
いったいたいたっ!　痛いっ!!
www
さぁっ、どこに置くかだよ
3つ目です
あ、3つまでならいけそうじゃない?
井上がいなくなったのはデカい(笑)
痛っっ!
では、ラスト1個!
も、最後の最後まで自分の力で運びたいね～…
運びます!!
頑張るよ!
見ててくれ!
っし～…
うぇえーい、頑張れぇー!!
キツイっしょ?
…落としていい?
ダメダメ!!
頑張れ～…
痛ぁぁぁぁああ!!!!!
やったー!!!
運びましたー!!!
あぁぇあぅ!!
うぉおわぁぅ!!!　お、わ、うわっ、危なっっ!!
どぉう?
どうどうどう?
釜爺でてる?(笑)
お前、釜爺なん?
部屋の4分の1ぐらいなくなっちゃった(笑)
これを、ここに置けば…
こうです
ぇ、というわけで皆さん、通帳と保険証、印鑑はここになります
覚えておくんだぞ!
はい!　というわけでいかがでしょうか
こんな感じです
ここが撮影部屋になるんですけども～
まぁ、撮影部屋が結構広すぎたんでー
全然、置ける感じではあります
まぁ、服だけじゃなくて
なんか物、小物とかー、撮影系の道具とかね
なんかいろんなものをここに入れていければいいなと思っております
釜爺です。
というわけで皆さん、ネットで買い物の際は!
買うもののサイズの確認をしっかりしましょう
じゃあな!!